el sonido de los bombardeos se escuchó
durante todo el día a medida que la
lucha continúa los residentes locales
están soportando el peso tanto las
fuerzas azerbaiyanas como las armenias
se han mostrado muy interesadas en
reflejar cómo se golpean mutuamente con
los ataques aéreos las muertes están
aumentando en ambos lados en la capital
de azerbaiján los hombres se están
haciendo fila para alistarse como
militares aunque nuestro ejército es
fuerte vine aquí para mostrarle a
nuestro gobierno que estoy listo estamos
listos para proteger nuestra patria en
cualquier momento en las calles de
ereván los armenios muestran reacciones
mixtas
no queremos una guerra pero si se nos
impone lucharemos no está en vano quiero
que todas las partes vuelvan a la mesa
de negociaciones lo único que quiero es
la paz me van golpes
el último estallido de este largo
conflicto comenzó el domingo en el
enclave de nagorno karabaj declarado
parte de azerbayán cuando se disolvió la
unión soviética pero que ha permanecido
en gran medida bajo el control de los
separatistas de etnia armenia
respaldados por el gobierno una guerra
total terminó con un alto el fuego
negociado por rusia en 1994 pero aún no
se ha firmado ningún acuerdo de paz
formal el secretario general exhortó
enérgicamente a las partes a que cesaran
inmediatamente los combates redujeron
las tensiones y volvieran a entablar
negociaciones significativas sin
condiciones previas ni retrase el
consejo de seguridad de la onu celebra
conversaciones de emergencia a puerta
cerrada este martes para tratar de
buscar una salida a las hostilidades en
curso